un dimanche matin à l'hypermarché pour
faire quelques emplettes pour les uns et
pour manifester pour d'autres après
l'ouverture le dimanche toute la journée
du casino de saint ferjeux le groupe a
franchi le pas fin novembre pour l'hyper
de châteaufarine libre-service caisses
automatiques et pas de salarié casino
entre 13 heures et 21 heures
inacceptable pour les syndicats
mobilisés depuis août dernier et la
première ouverture dominicale d'un hyper
casino à angers la mise en place des
caisses automatiques
ça va automatiquement créé une belle une
baisse des effectifs
moi je l'enfant par les indiens entre 5
et 10 % avaient un âge à deraa
récemment ma vie monsieur pastor encore
en table sur 30 pour fermer baisse des
effectifs sur le secteur kef
mais ce matin les manifestants n'étaient
pas des salariés casino mais plutôt des
militants politiques syndicaux et gilet
jaune pour qui cette question de
l'emploi doit être replacée dans un
cadre plus large peut pas accepter qu'on
nous supprime du travail et de l'humain
passe cas partout donc maintenant
partout que ce soit dans les services
publics dans le privé on supprime de
l'humain à chaque fois il ya plus
d'humains on se retrouve devant des
machines des bornes des trucs c'est pas
une société c'est une offensive
idéologique de la part des supermarchés
puisque nous disposons tous d'une somme
d'argent fini pour faire nos commissions
et donc ne dépenseront pas plus parce
que les magasins sont ouverts plus
longtemps
il s'agit donc de faire rentrer dans la
tête des gens l'idée que 1 nous devons
tous être à disposition de nos
employeurs en permanence par deux fois
en rhône alpes
casino a dû faire marche arrière face à
la mobilisation citoyenne et de certains
élus mais l'objectif reste le même
500 points de vente ouverts le dimanche
en 2021